I am Conan O'Brien of course or as I'm
known in New York local train on the
streets Express train
in the sheets pretty tough to leave this
town we've had such a great time here
yeah yeah the bad news is I'm leaving
New York the good news is I'm taking the
Giants with me so I see that hey I see
there's some hate out there right now so
many inspiring things around this city I
especially love the great Statue of
Liberty that welcomes people of all
nations to the promise of opportunity
and prosperity yeah great yeah we have
we have something like that in LA but we
call it the porn industry it's how we
got our start some of my best work big
election news this week on Tuesday on
Tuesday ten Republican men lost their
seats to Democratic women
amazing yeah no I don't have a joke for
that I just think it's pretty cool
President Trump was in China yesterday
she all saw that yeah yeah Trump he he
gave a speech calling North Korea a hell
no person deserves yeah apparently a
phrase he learned from Melania on their
wedding night now listen
[Applause]
you